[Music]
okay today's all about healthy food i'm
going to show you that eating well and
eating healthily can go hand in hand i'm
a chef so my whole day not just meal
times is devoted to food if i'm not
cooking it i'm tasting it or thinking
about it my other great passion in life
is fitness i've run over 10 marathons in
the last 10 years i have to get these
two sides of my life to work together
so get ready for my ultimate healthy
recipes dishes that are good for you
without any compromise on flavor
to start a fresh and fruity breakfast to
set you up for the day
quick birch muesli you can make in
minutes
next a liquid lunch which is generally
healthy
glorious gazpacho soup followed by a
wafer thin pineapple capacio for dessert
for dinner it's my youngest daughter
tilly joining me in the kitchen to cook
up a simple meal packed with goodness
teriyaki salmon filled with amiga oils
and superfood soba noodle salad
for dessert a delicious light and fizzy
spritz jelly
you would say done this is my ultimate
healthy food breakfast lunch and dinner
first up is my breakfast bircher muesli
birch muesli
traditionally gets made the night before
and left in the fridge i find that a
little bit too heavy and slightly stodgy
so it's the same principles
but a lot lighter
first thing the yoghurt i think live and
raw milk yogurt are best they're packed
with calcium enzymes and probiotics
which help your body absorb nutrients
it's interesting
because the kids especially would prefer
their muesli with milk but the yoghurt
so much better for them i like making it
literally 10 minutes before i want to
serve it
because it doesn't become stodgy
yoghurt in
apple juice that's a great way of
sweetening the muesli a couple of
tablespoons in
give that a little mix
now
sprinkle in the oats
i like putting two thirds in now to
absorb and almost double in size and the
last third
of oats in at the end
oats are low on the glycemic index which
means they slowly release energy to keep
you going right through to lunch
i quite like it when it just falls off
the spoon
you can see literally in seconds it's
got
thicker
the rest of the oats
in
so i've got different textures
now mix that up
nicely
and it literally takes three or four
minutes to put together
let's get a dry pan on
almonds incredibly healthy toasting them
even better flavor
flake them into the pan lightly toast
them
that gives a really nice sort of crunch
to the top of the muesli
[Music]
roll them around the pan so they're
evenly toasted out into a bowl
the exciting thing about putting your
own music together is that you're in
control blackberries summer raspberries
strawberries and so it changes berries
don't just taste great they're packed
with antioxidants and vitamins c and k
so just dot
the top of your muesli with your
blackberries generous on the
blackberries
sweetness tartness
acidic
and then just
sprinkle over
your nice almonds
i quite like a lot of crunch on top
so be generous
that looks fantastic
perfect way
to start the day
my quick birch muesli doesn't just taste
incredible it makes you feel fantastic
it's my ultimate healthy breakfast there
really is no better way to start the day
[Music]
next i'm putting the flavour back into
healthy food with a sensational lunch
and dinner
here are the key ingredients you'll need
to cook them
[Music]
first on my ultimate shopping list are
soba noodles these gray brown noodles
are made from buckwheat so they're
gluten free and high in protein
they're quick to cook and so versatile
use them in stir-fries soups and salads
like the one i'm making for dinner
salmon fillets are brimming with super
healthy amiga oils and so quick and
versatile to cook whether poached
grilled pan fried baked or quickest of
all rora sushi
i'm making a family favorite for my
healthy dinner teriyaki salmon
pomegranates have been revered since
ancient greek and egyptian times for
healing properties
today we know these little jewels are
packed with antioxidants minerals and
vitamins b c e and k
they are fantastic in middle eastern
dishes or scattered over fruit sellers
like the fine pineapple carpaccio i'm
making for lunch
i don't believe in fatty diets and diet
foods there's no cardboard tasting rice
cakes in our house let me tell you at
its simplest health eating for me is all
about fresh home-cooked food portion
control and a balanced diet and it
should be a pleasure to eat you should
never turn meal times into something you
dread for my ultimate healthy lunch i'm
showing you one of my favorite dishes
it's packed with vitamins and goodness
but it's also super tasty
gazpacho
for dessert sweet and refreshing
pineapple like you've never tasted
before
first job the gazpacho soup
for me the secret of a great gazpacho
is overripe tomatoes peppers cucumber a
little bit of heat with a garlic
we've got to leave it to marinade
first peppers cut around the flat edges
to minimize waste
[Music]
then chop
the nice thing about
making the gazpacho there's no set
recipe
because you can put it together
purely all tomatoes
half peppers half tomatoes
i like the flavor of the cucumber in
there as well that gives it that
freshness
the secret
of a great dispatcher is the longer you
leave it marinating
the better the flavor
so if you can get this done the night
before and left in the fridge
the results are stunning
the green and red peppers have subtly
complementary flavors and go well with
ripe tomatoes
start off by removing the bitter core
get a little knife
and just
put it in where the core is and twist it
around and you get this little core out
i remember my first experience
eating a gazpacho in spain
mind-blowing i've never forgotten that
quarter your tomatoes keeping the juicy
seeds that add so much depth of taste
nice then from there
cucumber
just peel that
the seeds i'm gonna leave in
that gives it the flavor
and the texture
cucumber and gazpacho
does exactly what it does in a pims it
sort of
freshens it up
and makes it mouth-watering slice that
in half
again
into quarters and chop
now to give gazpacho its unique texture
and thicken the soup bread and the
crispy the crust the better then garlic
thinly sliced
next spring onions nice and roughly
chopped and basil stalks and all we can
use stalks and
basil stalks parsley stalks tarragon
stalks they have the most amazing flavor
basil in
and now we'll start marinating
salt black pepper and a good coating of
olive oil this gives it a glossy creamy
flavor
and the cherry vinegar that's the
perfect vinegar
for the gazpacho it's a strong acidic
complement
to the flavors
then just mix it up and the smell
already is incredible
it doesn't look
like a gazpacho but by the time this
marinades
and all those flavors start getting to
know one another
all of a sudden you've got this huge
explosion
of contrast
now
push that down
in the restaurants
we press the marinade down overnight a
couple of big pans on top and we crush
all the ingredients and then blitz it
the next day
flavor is extraordinary leave all those
fresh ingredients packed with goodness
to marinade from half an hour to even
overnight and then when you blend it
it just comes together like this
sumptuous rich
delicious chilled soup
to go with my super tasty soup i've got
an ultra healthy and exciting dessert
cappuccio of pineapple which is a chefy
way of saying super thinly sliced
it's done with a twist
we're gonna have a delicious
flavored
salt
has to be flavored with vanilla simply
scrape out the vintage seeds and add to
sea salt along with the pod to store now
that basically keeps forever there's no
sail by day because it's salt and
vanilla so
so fragrant so delicious you don't need
much of this fragrant salt to intensify
the sweetness of the pineapple
pineapple
[Music]
sliced peeled pineapple into wafer thin
pieces it's almost like nice little
discs
slightly transparent
[Music]
once you've sliced the pineapple take
the flavor to another level
a light sprinkle of vanilla salt and
arrange the pineapple in a flower shape
[Music]
it's a beautiful way of finishing
a meal
the fragrance
other than
the crunch
with the salt
and the vanilla salt just marinades
the pineapple beautifully then scatter
nutrient rich pomegranate seeds over the
top
to finish finely shredded fresh mint
just
slice them
really thin
and then
give that nice cool
minty flavour
to the pineapple
my carpaccio is ready and my gazpacho
has been marinating in the fridge
time to blend the soup
in
onto your blender
and start off
nice and slowly
blend until super fine and gloriously
silky and serve refreshingly cold
get your bowl
and pour it in
now to finish it get some fresh basil
roll it nice and tight
and shred it
and then drop it into your bowl
fresh
chopped basil and then finally
just a touch of extra virgin olive oil
just to give that really nice additional
freshness
and look at that
healthy and delicious
gazpacho soup to me is a taste of
mediterranean sunshine in a bowl
followed by the wafer thin carpaccio of
pineapple with jewels of pomegranate
goodness for dessert
practically all of your five a day in
one incredible healthy lunch
it's not just me my whole family is
pretty sport mad my wife tarno runs
marathons jack's crazy about football
and swimming megan loves swimming too
and is in the local club holly's mad
about hockey and tilly plays netball for
the school
so a healthy diet is an important one
but we're pretty relaxed about it my
philosophy is simple try and eat less of
the bad stuff and eat more of the good
stuff and joining me in the kitchen is
my netball nut youngest tilly for dinner
it's amiga rich teriyaki salmon with a
bug wheat soba noodle salad brimming
with healthy greens and a light upper
old spritz jelly for dessert first job
the teriyaki marinade for the salmon
tilly
i'm gonna help daddy with the salmon
please
right
teriyaki delicious
sticky sweet salmon okay
first of all
i'd like you
a little seasoning on the salmon please
with salt and pepper
thank you
all right i want you to slice the garlic
one in front two behind
yeah
oh oh getting a bit faster in the old
age huh
good girl
thank you right garlic in with the
ginger
so we're gonna make a marinade
okay do you know what a marinade is it's
what you cook something in that's right
so let's start off with
soy sauce
three tablespoons one
good two good three this is rice wine
also known as mirin
one in
i know what that is that's maple syrup
it's a bit like pure gold
beautiful and a little touch of olive
oil
wow it smells really good
i want you to rub
the salmon in the marinade if you can
get a chance to do this the night before
the salmon actually changes color but
it's fine even with 10 or 15 minutes
before you start cooking it
does the ginger and garlic give it a
different taste
do you know what it helps improve the
taste when we cook it i have this really
nice glaze on there okay
right let's put that in the fridge to
marinade and we'll start the jellies
to follow the teriyaki salmon a grown up
light dessert
prosecco and aperol spreads jelly
start by soaking gelatin sheets in cold
water
pour prosecco 100 milliliters of water
and cast the sugar into the pan
[Music]
heat until the sugar's dissolved then
add your gelatin sheets
leave the mixture cool top up with more
prosecco and a dash of the bitter sweet
italian aperol
then pour into tumblers over orange
slices and leave to set in the fridge
all the refreshment of a spritz in a
perfect jelly form
the teriyaki salmon's marinading time to
get on with the noodle and vitamin
packed veg and seed salad
server noodles why are they this color
they're this color because they're made
out of
buckwheat
okay and then we're gonna drop them in
so nice and careful if you slide them
that way
and then you go like that in your hand
and that will show you there
and then look
hold them like that and drop them into
the pan okay got them yeah okay so hold
on tight
off you go
nice do they take longer to cook than
normal
actually take literally five minutes now
what are they
[Music]
sugar snap please
okay
that's so crunchy really crunchy now
carrot
and kale
i'm gonna show you a really quick way of
slicing carrot ribbons so just come
yes it's a down like peeling them but
that's right off we go there we go
nice big long ribbons
sugar snap peas in yeah okay into the
noodles
we've got two
oh thank you wake up daddy next
kale now you know how good that is for
you right yeah
kale
in right how the ribbons
okay good oh
that's nice
you you okay we like some salt and
pepper on your little cat
[Laughter]
ribbons go in
good girl i didn't forget any like you
did so excuse me
and because we've shaved them really
thinly like this
how long do you think they're going to
take to cook
about a minute oh it looks so yummy it
does look yummy doesn't it
now we're going to drain
the noodles
that is beautiful see how the kale's
what happens if you cook um the
vegetables for too long would they just
go a bit hard they'll go soft and mushy
okay
and then
we're gonna drop the noodles
in
but now
i'm gonna make those noodles taste even
better i'd like you to put a little bit
of salt and pepper on there for me
please
next
chop
spring onions through watch your fingers
please
i'm gonna put a dressing
on there ginger goes in
i can smell that from there you can
count me
how nice it's gonna be like a
multi-season salad isn't it no
what's that a little smell
um
sesame seeds oh yeah that's right sesame
oil a touch of sesame oil over
okay
rice wine vinegar
a little splash
okay
and then finally
and it will touch
my soy sauce and let you drizzle that in
please
that's it
one little final
ingredient what's that seaweed whose
favorite's that
jack's hollies and mine
slice it into strips
okay
i'm gonna chop that
oh how is that
good i want you to sprinkle that
on top of the noodles
and i'll squeeze the lemon juice
oh excuse me
once also had a lemon shower today
the soba noodle salad is ready now
we'll get on and cook the salmon
oh it looks good doesn't it
boom let's go
boom right pan nice and hot
what did i show you when you put fish in
the pan which way do you put in
you put it in a
skin downfall that's right and
then there's the pan there and you put
it in there and you lay away from you if
you lay it towards you what happens it
will spit it yeah splash that's right so
take your time
good girl
and the last one good girl very slicky
very slippery
this one's so fresh nice
nice a nice little bit of ginger on
there now a little bit of garlic it
smells of a mixture of all the flavors
doesn't it so a nice color on the salmon
nice and crispy nice and crispy that's
right
and i'd like you to pour
the rest of marinade over for me please
nice
okay
now the salmon's gonna glaze now
well done
you're getting good at this cooking
stuff you know that would you like to be
a chef when you grow up
yeah really would like to have your own
restaurant one day
i'd like to have a bakery a bakery me
and jack we're planning on opening one
together oh and then you do the paninis
and make the coffees and i do the cakes
and the cookies then it's gonna have
like scrambled eggs for breakfast so
you've already thought this out yeah we
were planning it the other night and
when we couldn't sleep
and who's going to be the head chef and
who's going to be the sous chef no we're
not going to do that because we've both
got different roles in it oh i see this
is well thought out yeah but we're not
going to need anybody else apart from me
and him so no other people that was nice
it sounds amazing
you got the spoon here like this okay
and just tilt the pan i'll tilt the pan
you glaze the salmon for me please
now today am i done
uh already
do you keep the
ginger on top of it
what was your favorite type of salmon
when you were little
salmon fish cakes
oh i like those you like those
how does that look it looks delicious
i'd like you to carry that very
carefully over the table okay and i'll
carry your noodles
ready
let's go well done
so i'm fascinated with this restaurant
you and jack are going to open
yeah
this is my ultimate healthy dinner it's
fresh home-cooked and full of goodness
but most importantly it's absolutely
delicious
meg holly mom
dinner
so we have a delicious turkey salmon
with soba noodles these look and sound
super healthy
i think we did well high five
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
you